MemodoAI just got an update.
In the next few minutes, we'll cover what's new.
The headline being that MemodoAI can now work with your Microsoft 365.
Plus, reusable skills, chat projects, and a handful of quality of life touches.
Everything you already know still works exactly the same.
The biggest addition, MemodoAI can now read your own Microsoft 365.
Your Outlook mail, calendar, OneDrive, and SharePoint files, Excel, OneNote, tasks,
and contacts, right inside a chat.
It works through what's called an MCP server.
Think of it as a connector that lets the assistant reach an outside system on your
behalf.
You turn it on in the Composer, click MCP Servers, and tick Microsoft 365 Aligned.
A quick note on the connection.
If you see a green dot next to Microsoft 365, it's live.
If it's disconnected, which can happen when your session ages out,
click the small plug icon and then Tune Initialize.
A couple of seconds later, it flips to Active, and you're good.
Now, I'll ask something simple.
Using Microsoft 365, what is my display name and job title?
Notice the line under the response.
Ran get current user in Microsoft 365.
That tells you exactly which tool it used.
You can click it to see more.
Three things to keep in mind.
First, it runs as you.
It uses your own Microsoft sign-in,
so it can only ever see what you could already see.
Second, it's read-only for now.
It can read your mail and files,
but it won't send, edit, or delete anything.
And third, name a target.
Find the ACME contract in SharePoint
works far better than Find My Important Documents.
Anything it reads back still passes through
the same personal data checks as the rest of Momodo AI.
The second big addition is skills.
A skill is a small, reusable playbook,
a set of instructions for how you handle a recurring task
that the assistant pulls in only when it's relevant,
instead of you retyping the same guidance every time.
The clever part is that Momodo AI always knows
a skill's name and one-line description,
but only loads the full instructions
when a task actually matches,
so the assistant can effectively know
a whole library of procedures
without carrying all of them in every conversation.
There are two ways to use one.
You can just let the assistant pick it.
An enabled skill applies automatically
when your request matches its description,
or you can invoke it by name.
Type a dollar sign in the message box
and a picker lists your skills.
I'll pick meeting notes
and paste in a rough team sync transcript.
Look at the result.
The assistant reshaped my messy notes
into clean sections, attendees, decisions, action items with owners and due dates,
and open
questions. That structure came from the skill, not from me asking for it. You
manage skills from the
skills panel in the left rail. That's where you create, edit, and organize them. To
make one,
click the plus and choose write skill instructions. Give it a name, a description
that's specific
about when it should apply, and the instructions themselves in Markdown. A pattern
that works well,
borrowed from the skills already in here, is three headings. When to use, procedure,
and output format. Save it, and it's in your library. One more thing worth knowing.
Skills
are versioned and can be shared, so a team can build up a trusted set of playbooks.
Fix a procedure
once and everyone using it gets the fix. Two more capabilities came with this
update. The first is
for people who build agents, chaining. In the agent builder under advanced, there's
a multi-agent
orchestration section with a chain option. It lets you run a fixed sequence of
agents one after
another. The output of one feeds the next. Here you can see a chain where a primary
agent hands
off to an uppercase bot that transforms its output. It's worth reaching for when a
task
has genuinely distinct steps. Just remember each step adds tokens and time, so most
everyday tasks
don't need it. The second is memory, and this one's for everyone. Memido AI can now
actively
remember things you tell it. Watch. I'll say, from now on, remember that I'm on the
front-end team
and I prefer concise, bulleted answers.
The Assistant confirms what it saved
right there in its reply.
Those items now live in your Memories panel,
the brain icon in the left rail,
where you can read, edit, or delete them.
It's tied to your account only
and there's a toggle to turn it off whenever you want.
There's nothing to set up.
It just works wherever you chat.
If your chat history is getting long,
projects will help.
You can now group related conversations
into project folders shown at the top of the sidebar.
Click New Project, give it a name,
and you've got a home for, say, all your Q3 planning chats.
Think of projects as folders that group conversations,
where bookmarks, which you already have,
are tags you apply across them.
A few smaller touches you'll notice as you work.
There's a new context meter,
the little circle in the message bar.
Hover it, and you'll see how full
the model's context window is for the current chat. It's a usage gauge, not a bill.
It shows
how much room is left, not a cost. When a long chat starts to fill up, that's a
good moment to
start a fresh one. Office files look better too. When you attach a Word doc, a
spreadsheet,
a slide deck, or a CSV, it now shows as a proper preview card rather than a plain
download link.
And a couple of little things. New conversations get a title immediately instead of
after the
first reply, and hovering any message shows you when it was sent. That's what's new.
If you want
a refresher on the basics, the model picker, file search, building agents, the main
getting started
guide covers all of that, and none of it changed. Thanks for watching.